Samsung alors c'est récemment plein de
nouveaux produits des smartphones qui se
plient Galaxy Z3 Galaxy Z flip 5
démontre également Galaxy watch 6 Galaxy
watch 6 classic il y a également des
tablettes les Galaxy Tab S9 bref vous
allez apprendre aujourd'hui 10 astuces
Samsung qui change tout et ça c'est cool
la première astuce et qui est la base de
la base de la base qui est extrêmement
importante c'est d'abord un compte
Samsung pourquoi parce que sans compte
Samsung vous allez pas réellement
faire expérience vos photos et fichiers
vont pouvoir naviguer d'un smartphone à
une tablette d'une tablette un
ordinateur d'un ordinateur à une
tablette très facilement en
synchronisant vous allez profiter de
Samsung pay du Wallet de Samsung de
Smart things donc contrôler tout votre
domotique à la maison directement avec
notamment vos appareils Samsung bref si
vous avez un produit de Samsung pensez
réellement à vous créer un compte
Samsung c'est supra important la
deuxième astuce cette concerne la
communication entre vos appareils par
exemple si vous prenez une photo avec
votre smartphone on va prendre par
exemple ici le Galaxy Z flic 5 et bien
vous avez pris une photo et vous voulez
venir éditer cette photo directement
soit sur votre table S9 ultra soit
pourquoi pas sur votre Galaxy book 3
ultra sur Lightroom Photoshop à vous de
voir bien vous avez deux solutions qui
s'offrent à vous la première c'est coûte
cher vous permettra de partager vos
photos vos fichiers vos vidéos
directement avec les personnes à
proximité qui disposent également de
l'appareil de Samsung vous allez sur
kickshare vous cliquez dessus vous voyez
les personnes à proximité et vous
envoyez directement votre fichier qui va
transiter grâce au wifi sur l'appareil à
côté mais si vous avez un fichier qui
est un petit peu trop lumineux vous avez
un truc qui est super bien et bien vous
allez pour partager vous allez dans
quick share et là vous allez voir une
petite case QR code vous cliquez dessus
alors soit vous avez un QR code pour
partager directement à quelqu'un qui a
un smartphone à côté qui vient flasher
qui envoie soit en dessous vous avez un
lien et ça c'est link chérie de Samsung
qui vous permettra de transmettre ce
lien à n'importe quelle personne quelle
que soit son appareil Samsung ou autre
pour pouvoir télécharger vos fichiers et
c'est tout l'intérêt ici d'avoir un
compte Samsung parce que Samsung va
télécharger vos fichiers dans le Cloud
jusqu'à 5 Go et va les conserver pendant
3 jours pour que un ami ou un collègue
puisse venir télécharger votre fichier
extrêmement facilement et ça
gratuitement et au bout des trois jours
soyez rassurés tout va être effacé du
club de Samsung la troisième astuce
concerne la création un contenu qui est
vraiment facilité avec vos nouveaux
smartphones de Samsung Galaxy 7 plus 5
Galaxy 7 fold 5 moi mon coup de cœur va
sur le Galaxy S65 d'ailleurs je sais pas
lequel est le vote dites le moi dans les
commentaires si vous avez un Galaxy Z
flip 5 ça marche aussi avec un autre
smartphone de Samsung et une galaxie ou
à 6 ou 6 classique comme moi ici au
poignet et bien vous prenez votre
smartphone à distance je vais le mettre
en mode Flex par exemple et sur ma
montre je vais pouvoir venir lancer
directement mon appareil photo en
cliquant sur mon icône je vais pouvoir
voir mon aperçu directement sur ma
montre je vous conseille de mettre un
timer à 3 secondes parce que si vous
appuyez sur votre montre à ce moment-là
et bien vous risquez d'être avec votre
monde devant sur la photo c'est pas
terrible vous mettez un petit timer de 3
secondes et vous pouvez ensuite voir
directement l'aperçu de votre photo sur
votre montre et il y a un autre truc qui
est génial et je vais adorer justement
ici avec la Watch 6 Classic et bien on
va tourner la molette de ma montre je
vais pouvoir venir zoomer et venir
zoomer beaucoup plus précisément que ce
que je pourrais faire avec mon
smartphone parce que je vais avancer
cran par cran par cran par cran et une
fois que j'ai fini et bien j'ai qu'à
fermer en appuyant sur le bouton bas à
deux ma montre ça fait mon application
sur mon smartphone je donne une autre
astuce que j'adore pour la création de
contenu notamment ici sur le Galaxy z85
c'est l'auto frameing vous avez qu'à
venir cliquer sur cette icône sur votre
smartphone et lui il va faire de
l'auto-streaming c'est à dire qu'il va
venir se recentrer en permanence sur
vous ça c'est génial pour la création de
contenu je pense notamment aux vidéos
Tik Tok vous avez qu'à vous déplacer
vous avancez vous reculez et lui il va
bien faire le point sur vous et même si
vous vous décalez sur le côté et votre
petite astuce vous voulez pas venir vous
embêter vous ne déclencher votre photo
avec la paume de votre main tac ça prend
la photo et vous êtes tranquille la
quatrième astuce qui est va bien c'est
que si vous avez votre smartphone et
vous avez votre tablette à côté que la
tablette elle est full patate et que
votre smartphone commence vraiment à se
décharger au niveau de la batterie et
bien vous pouvez utiliser votre tablette
pour venir recharger directement votre
smartphone il vous suffit de prendre
votre cordon usb-c usb-c vous branchez
dans la tablette dans smartphone et
l'énergie va se transférer directement
de votre tablette à votre smartphone et
ça fonctionne également de galaxies Z à
Galaxy Z la 5e astuce
c'est plus l'heure de l'Espagne si vous
adorez le stylet de Samsung que vous
ayez un Galaxy S23 ultra avec son espèce
à l'intérieur ou que vous ayez acheté un
stylet fold edition ou que vous ayez
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs pris le nouveau
accessoire la Slim Espagne case de
Samsung qui vous permet d'avoir un Spain
extrêmement fin pour votre Galaxy Z fold
5 et bien vous allez pouvoir venir
utiliser votre s-pn pour faire des tas
de choses sur votre Galaxy Z fold 5 vous
pouvez notamment le prendre dans les
zones de recherche et vous écrivez à la
main ce que vous recherchez votre
écriture sera donc transformé en texte
ça marche bien évidemment sur galaxy Z3
mais également sur votre Galaxy Tab S9
ultra et celle là où c'est super
important d'avoir un compte Samsung
parce que vous allez pouvoir commencer à
écrire des notes sur votre galaxie Tab
S9 ultra et lorsque vous devez partir et
bien vouloir acheter dans votre sac et
vous pouvez continuer dans les
transports en commun pourquoi pas par
exemple sur un Galaxy Z3 vos notes vont
remonter en permanence dans le Cloud
pour redescendre sur tous vos appareils
et être mis à jour partout et d'ailleurs
autre petite astuce qui est vachement
bien dans l'appli Samsung note vous
pouvez venir écrire directement avec
votre expert ou alors pourquoi pas bien
convertir en texte en cliquant sur
l'icône avec un stylet et un petit thé à
côté ça va venir reconnaître votre
écriture et la convertir directement en
texte ça c'est vachement bien pour
pouvoir ensuite envoyer vos notes en
copier-coller très facilement la sixième
astuce ça va être pour la
personnalisation de son smartphone il a
le gros coup de cœur il se fait sur le
Galaxy Z flip 5 parce que grâce à son
grand écran externe et bien on peut
aller vachement plus loin vous pouvez
choisir dans vos paramètres quelle image
quelle photo vous allez mettre sur votre
écran d'accueil mais est-ce que vous
savez vous pouvez mettre également une
vidéo ou pourquoi pas un gif moi je vous
montre avec une vidéo que j'ai
téléchargé directement je mets ma vidéo
et après je peux venir totalement
customiser l'expérience c'est-à-dire
modifier mon horloge l'emplacement de
l'horloge modifie également la police
d'écriture de l'horloge mais également
sa couleur pour qu'elle soit
parfaitement adéquation avec ma vidéo ou
avec ma photo au choix je peux choisir
d'afficher le niveau de batterie ou pas
ça peut être aussi vachement bien et je
peux également mettre un cadre je peux
changer la forme du cadre changer
l'opacité changer la couleur et pourquoi
pas d'ailleurs mettre des lettres je
peux également modifier la façon de
revenir s'afficher mes notifications
soit un petit point rouge sur la gauche
soit carrément en haut à gauche une
petite liste de notification ou alors
choisir carrément de ne rien mettre ni
horloge ni batterie ni notification et
avoir juste ma photo ou ma vidéo ça me
permet d'avoir vachement combinaison et
de totalement venir personnaliser
l'écran externe de mon galaxy Z5 ce qui
en plus super ici c'est que vous avez
accès à vachement de widget vous pouvez
venir à les déplacer à très facilement
on va en appuyer long et en glissant
votre doigts pour venir les supprimer
également mais on est un peu limité sur
le nombre d'applications pour venir
utiliser sur l'écran externe et bien
restez parce que justement j'ai une
astuce géniale qui vous permettra de
venir utiliser toutes les applications
que vous voulez sur l'écran externe de
votre Galaxy Z flip 5 avant de vous
montrer ça j'ai une astuce qui vachement
cool lorsque vous les veniez regarder
YouTube ou Netflix directement sur
l'écran externe de votre smartphone
pendant que vous travaillez par exemple
et bien vous mettez votre Galaxy 7 flip
5 en mode tente comme ça vous voyez le
contenu directement à côté de vous ça
c'est quand même vachement pratique vous
pouvez venir également personnaliser le
fond d'écran de vos appels ça c'est
valable pour tous les smartphones de
Samsung c'est grâce à leur expérience
one ui qui est juste topissime dans
l'application d'appel vous avez les
trois petits points vous appuyez dessus
vous allez dans les paramètres dans
l'arrière-plan d'appel et là vous venez
choisir ce que vous voulez une photo et
pourquoi pas d'ailleurs une vidéo sur ça
quand même vachement plus dynamique là
ça vaut l'appliquer pour toutes les
personnes qui vous appelleront mais si
vous voulez venir personnaliser la fiche
de quelqu'un vous pouvez faire également
la même chose uniquement sur la fiche
d'un interlocuteur en mettant sa photo
directement ou pourquoi pas une image
qui vous fait penser à lui ou elle et
justement je donne une astuce qui est
juste top ici pour venir ouvrir toutes
les applications que vous voulez sur
l'écran externe de votre Galaxy Z flip 5
ça aujourd'hui c'est pas possible mais
on peut venir le faire il faut que vous
téléchargez l'application qui s'appelle
good lock sans Galaxy store pas sur le
Play Store mais bien sur l'application
Galaxy Store vous recherchez ensuite
multistar que vous venez installer vous
allez dans I love Galaxy foldable et
vous installez le launcher widget vous
venez l'activer bien évidemment dans la
liste de vos widgets et là vous allez
pouvoir venir choisir toutes les
applications que vous voulez venir
ouvrir directement sur l'écran externe
de votre Galaxy Z flip 5 je vais pouvoir
mettre Instagram Disney plus que j'avais
pas avant discord et même Tik Tok alors
j'en conviens le format est pas parfait
parfait mais c'est quand même vachement
cool la septième astuce elle est pour
les Galaxy Z flip 5 et Z fold 5
l'intérêt c'est de smartphones c'est le
flex mode vous pouvez venir activer une
option qui n'est pas cochée par défaut
et qui est quand même vachement cool
pour ça vous allez dans les paramètres
dans fonction avancées dans Lab et vous
activez le volet du mode Flex ça vous
permettra lorsque votre smartphone est
payé à 90 degrés donc en mode Flex et
bien d'avoir accès à plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités vous pouvez venir
modifier la luminosité venir modifier le
volume vous pouvez également déplacer
vos fonctions préférées pour venir les
retrouver directement avec glisser
déposer vous avez également un touchpan
pour avoir comme une petite souris vous
pouvez également l'utiliser à deux
doigts pour venir naviguer et vous avez
même un pointeur qui est totalement
personnalisable via un lien dans le menu
je trouve ça juste cool parce qu'en fait
j'ai envie d'aller beaucoup plus loin et
d'améliorer significativement
l'expérience en mode Flex la 8ème astuce
est d'utiliser votre Galaxy Z fold 5
comme une tablette comme vous avez un
smartphone qui vient réellement
s'agrandir vous pouvez venir tirer
profit de ce grand écran pour l'utiliser
réellement comme une tablette la
nouveauté cette année c'est que vous
pouvez venir ajouter jusqu'à 8
applications en bas et votre Galaxy Z3
vous affichera 4 applications récentes
soit un total de 12 applications
directement en bas merci vous pouvez
également changer facilement
d'application en passant votre doigt
dessus directement vous cliquez tac tac
vous passez de l'application quand vous
êtes sur une application et bien vous
avez en bas
à gauche grille avec les 9
points vous arriverez directement sur la
liste de toutes vos applications comme
ça vous pourrez choisir une nouvelle
application ou pourquoi pas lancer
également du multitâche très facilement
ça évite de devoir sortir de son
application d'ouvrir ensuite le tiroir
d'application de choisir une application
bref on gagne du temps et ça c'est
vachement cool et si vous voulez faire
disparaître cette petite barre en bas
qui vous embête vous êtes sur une
application vous laissez votre doigt
appuyer dessus elle va partir et la même
manière pour la faire revenir vous
laissez votre doigt appuyer en bas elle
va remonter c'est très pratique il y a
un truc qui est vachement cool sur
multitâche vous pouvez avoir jusqu'à
trois applications sur votre écran plus
une fenêtre pop-up au milieu mais vous
avez la barre des tâches qui est si
prend un petit peu de place et bien vous
pouvez venir la faire disparaître pour
gagner encore en visibilité sur ce grand
écran intérieur vous allez dans vos
paramètres vous allez dans fonction
avancées dans multi fenêtres et vous
venez cocher la case plein écran en
affichage fractionné je vous conseille
également de venir activer deux autres
options ce sont les deux options
glissement que vous venez activer et qui
viendront aussi améliorer l'expérience
ça c'est cool il y a un autre truc qui
est vachement bien lorsque vous avez
créé un multitâche qui vous plaît
réellement avec trois applications ou
deux applications ouvertes en cliquant
au centre les petits points que vous
avez là vous allez voir une étoile vous
cliquez dessus ça viendra ajouter
directement en bas dans vos applications
vous allez garder ici alors attention si
vous avez déjà 8 applications ça
marchera pas faudra venir en virer une
et si vous avez la place vous pouvez
venir ici mettre différentes
configurations multitâche la 9e astuce
est pour rendre le clavier de Samsung un
peu plus pratique ça c'est vraiment un
point qui est important pour moi au
niveau du Galaxy cette fold 5 par défaut
vous allez avoir les touches qui vont
être espacées pour venir taper
directement avec vos deux doigts que ce
soit plus simple alors soit vous aimez
cette configuration et tant mieux ça
vous préférez que ce soit un peu plus
centré et je vais vous montrer comment
faire dans vos paramètres vous allez
dans le clavier Samsung puis dans taille
et transparence vous pouvez bien
évidemment ici venir modifier la taille
mettre le clavier un peu plus haut un
peu plus bas comme l'avenir également le
déplacer vous pouvez choisir
l'écartement des lettres le rapprocher
l'écarter vous avez le choix entre le
clavier standard qui prendra toutes
l'espace en bas de votre smartphone le
clavier fractionné qui vous gardera un
espèce de blanc au milieu ou alors le
clavier flottant et la 10e astuce c'est
venir personnaliser l'affichage des
notifications sur votre smartphone
smartphone ou tablette et bien vous
allez dans vos paramètres vous êtes dans
les notifications style de pop-up et
vous choisissez le style de notification
lumineuse vous allez pouvoir venir
changer pas mal de choses au niveau du
cadre de l'épaisseur de la grandeur du
trait des effets que vous allez avoir
autour des notifications pour avoir
vraiment ce qui vous plaît et que ça
vous mette en joie et même modifier la
couleur et ça une fois de plus c'est
vachement cool d'ailleurs si il y a un
de ces produits qui vous intéresse et
bien évidemment je vous mets un lien en
bas dans la description et si vous
voulez un smartphone qui ressemble pas à
celui des autres et bien vous avez des
coloris exclusifs sur le site de
SAMSUNG.com notamment ici sur le Galaxy
S7 flip 5 vous allez avoir de l'argent
du cobalt du vert et du jaune et sur le
Galaxy Z fold 5 en coloris exclusive
vous aurez de l'argent et du cobalt une
fois de plus à des offres super
intéressantes pour venir acheter
l'ensemble de ces produits sur le site
de SAMSUNG.com j'aurais bien évidemment
un lien juste en bas dans la description
et d'ailleurs si vous n'avez pas regardé
ma vidéo avec plein d'astuces pour
savoir comment utiliser en profondeur
votre galaxie effet 5 la vidéo est ici
foncez la voir vous serez pas déçu